to all of my subscribers and viewers on
YouTube I would like to wish you a Merry
Christmas and a Happy New Year and if
there's other holidays you want to throw
in there as well I'm perfectly content
to to see those as part of the package
deal the main thing is conveying
goodwill and saying that this is a in
some ways special time of year for me
Christmas is special for for three
different reasons well really for you
can see one of them right right here and
I'm not sure if it will be snowing where
you are on Christmas day I suspect from
many of you it won't be nor am I sure
since i'm recording this ahead of time
whether it will be where I am on
Christmas Day in Wisconsin right now in
in New York it's snowing pretty heavily
and I suspect that it's going on in the
Midwest as well and for me this is part
of the Christmas season this light you
know when also against falling snow
flake clumps that says that says
holidays just as much as pine wreaths
and advent candles get together and all
the other things that they go along with
it so I'm very happy that we have this
this now although it means a little bit
of work for me it's also the the end of
the academic year by now students are
out of school and enjoying themselves
taking some some time for leisure for
rest for catching catching up grades
have been turned in and perhaps aren't
known yet that might be a good thing for
some people and for me I actually I'm
teaching a class right now but but I a
it's an online class so I at least don't
have to show up to work and and do
things face to face which is kind of
nice i get to work from home so that's
the second thing the third thing is i
come from a very large and close family
my mother and father long sense since
have passed away and same thing with my
grandparents and most of my great aunts
and uncles but my cousins and
my other aunts and uncles are still with
us and we're pretty close and I like to
spend time with them at Christmas it's a
time to catch up find out what
everybody's been doing and see who's
grown eat some good food together trade
some jokes maybe watch a game hang out
and just enjoy each other's company and
that's that's very important for me then
there's the religious aspect and again
you know if saying Merry Christmas is
not your thing that's quite all right
you can still accept my well wishes and
if you want to wish me well for any
other holidays I'm perfectly happy to
have other people's well wishes this is
a time of joy it's a time of celebration
liturgically it is celebrating the the
entry into time of hope and joy and love
incarnate in a very vulnerable form and
now you can say of course while he's
probably born in august and you know the
Roman Holiday blah blah blah blah blah
this is when we celebrate it and there's
nothing wrong with that any more than
there is with switching other holidays
around the thing that matters is the
liturgical significance the ritual the
cycle and all these things are coming
together as they do every Christmas for
for me for my family for my friends some
you know more concerned about it than
others and I just wanted to sort of peel
back the curtain so to speak and show
you a little bit of my life and from
that portion of my life to wish all of
you a Merry Christmas and Happy New Year
I will be doing an event New Year's Eve
another one of these google hangouts on
air hopefully it'll go a little bit that
you know more smoothly than the last
time but I'm guessing most of you are
going to have plenty of other things to
do New Year's Eve so if you're there
I'll wish you happy new years then
otherwise I wish you happy new years now
and safe travels